ladies and gentlemen
walter pal madrigal and billboard
all right
it's the first one yeah why don't you go
over there
yeah we're doing the odd couple thing
here you're drinking beer i got the
[ __ ] tea right
were you uh not because i'm a health nut
i'm a big time booze hound and i take
gaps take gaps off right so right now do
you talk about that all you take uh you
just had a big weekend you uh
i taped a special up about 10 days ago
so i didn't booze for like
like six seven weeks before that to get
the the pizza and beer weight off
so i don't have a big pumpkin head when
i go out there hard to get trashed
enough on twitter i don't need to help
them
right so that's why i do then i lose
like 10 pounds of booze weight and then
i just go right back to being a [ __ ]
animal and then
it's so funny this time i'm trying to
hold it off for a couple of weeks that's
all every time we hang out it's
hilarious because you know we there's
booze we're comics there's booze
everywhere we get free liquor everywhere
we go there's
amazing the willpower that he has
because i always go hey you want a beer
like no i have
there's cold stellas over there and i'm
[ __ ] loving them and i i say you want
to be here and he goes no he said i
haven't been drinking and then i'll try
to take
it you know days off and i last for two
days three days and then i'm right back
at it i can't [ __ ] do it you gotta
get through six once you get through six
then it gets to the point where you
don't want to give it away you don't
want to start over again but it's brutal
trying to start when i start when i quit
boozing i have to i have to try it like
18 times because then i'll be like all
right [ __ ] it i'll start tomorrow and
i'll and i'll drink but i'm not an
alcoholic i just i just really enjoy it
i think people a little overly sensitive
i think i'm an alcoholic i really do
you're too successful to be an alcoholic
yeah i guess let's piss off all the
addicts that are watching this that's
wrong that is that is the kind of
misinformation that we are trying to
stop right here
that's exactly it yeah
no if you're if you're watching this at
home if you're successful you're not an
addict at all and all those people
that you're hurting need to toughen up
okay
cause you're right let them bring a
check home right let them bring a check
home